this is the emergency backpack that
journalist
igor ilyash takes with him when he
leaves the house just in case he gets
arrested
it has all the basics underwear
toothbrush and toothpaste
and the photographs of his wife katya
carefully printed out to look at in
detention
she is now in prison jailed last
thursday for two years
for live streaming a protest alongside
her colleague twenty-three-year-old
daria chiltsova
ilyash was allowed a brief meeting with
her just after the sentencing
on trial now is another journalist
katarina borisevic
she was reporting on the case of roman
bondarenko who died last november
after he was attacked by suspected
government thugs
the official version of events was that
he was drunk
boriseevich quoting the emergency doctor
at the hospital
said that he was not now both she and
the doctor
face three years
physicists
far from the police violence of the last
seven months being investigated
it seems to be glorified instead in this
video special forces show off their
skills to high school students
and remember this is europe not north
korea
last week police raided the homes and
offices of 90
journalists and human rights activists
the belarusian association of
journalists office was sealed
equipment taken away andrei bastoone
sits chairman was detained briefly but
now he's back home
waiting to see what the authorities do
next
desk is untouched since the day she left
it
her daughter daria turning 18 while her
mother was in detention
the outcome of her trial almost
certainly a jail term
because these are show trials criminal
prosecutions to shut down the free media
so the abuses of the regime cannot be
told
[Applause]
as a journalist himself igor ilyash says
it only makes him more determined
[Music]
we asked him to ask katya what she
wanted the world to know
when he saw her at their last meeting
that in belarus journalism is a crime
she said
diana magney sky news moscow